if we return to
the big ambitious dream of alpha fold
that may be the early steps on a very
long journey in um
in biology
do you think the same kind of approach
can use to predict the structure and
function of more complex biological
systems so multi-protein interaction
and then
i mean you can go out from there yeah
just simulating bigger and bigger
systems that eventually simulate
something like the human brain or the
human body it's just the big mush the
mess of the beautiful
resilient mess of biology do you do you
see that as a long-term vision i do and
i think um you know if you think about
what are the things top things i wanted
to apply ai to once we had powerful
enough systems biology and curing
diseases and understanding biology uh
was right up there you know top of my
list that's one of the reasons i
personally pushed that myself and with
alpha fold but i think alpha fold uh
amazing as it is is just the beginning
um and and and i hope it's evidence of
uh what could be done with computational
methods so um you know alpha fold solve
this this huge problem of the structure
of proteins but biology is dynamic so
really what i imagine from here we're
working on all these things now is
protein protein interaction um protein
ligand binding so reacting with
molecules
then you want to get build up to
pathways and then
eventually a virtual cell that's my
dream uh maybe in the next 10 years and
i've been talking actually to a lot of
biologists friends of mine paul nurse
who runs the quick institute amazing
biologists nobel prize-winning
biologists we've been discussing for 20
years now virtual cells could you build
a virtual simulation of a cell and if
you could that would be incredible for
biology and disease discovery because
you could do loads of experiments on the
virtual cell and then only at the last
stage validate it in the wet lab so you
could you know that in terms of the
search space of discovering new drugs
you know it takes 10 years roughly to go
from uh to to go from you know
identifying a target to
having a drug candidate um maybe that
could be shortened to you know by an
order of magnitude with if you could do
most of that that that work in silico so
in order to get to a virtual cell
we have to build up uh understanding of
different parts of biology and the
interactions and and um so we you know
we every every few years we talk about
this with i talked about this with paul
and then finally last year after alpha
fault i said now is the time we can
finally go for it and alpha falls the
first proof point that this might be
possible
and he's very excited and we have some
collaborations with his with his lab
that they're just across the road
actually from us it's you know wonderful
being here in kings cross with the quick
institute across the road and um and i
think the next steps you know i think
there's going to be some amazing
advances in biology built on top of
things like alpha fold uh we're already
seeing that with the community doing
that after we've open sourced it and
released it um and uh you know i also i
often say that i think
uh if you think of
mathematics is the perfect description
language for physics i think ai might be
end up being the perfect description
language for biology because
biology is so messy it's so emergent so
dynamic and complex
i think i find it very hard to believe
we'll ever get to something as elegant
as newton's law's emotions to describe a
cell right it's just too complicated um
so i think ai is the right tool for this
you have to uh you have to start at the
basic building blocks and use ai to run
the simulation for all those building
blocks so have a
very strong way to do prediction of what
given these building blocks what kind of
biology how the the function
and the evolution of that biological
system it's almost like a cellular
automata you have to run it you can't
analyze it from a high level you have to
take the basic ingredients figure out
the rules yeah and let it run but in
this case the rules are very difficult
to figure out yes yes learn them that's
exactly it so it's the biology too
complicated to figure out the rules it's
it's it's too emergent too dynamic say
compared to a physics system like the
motion of a planet yeah right and and so
you have to learn the rules and that's
exactly the type of systems that we're
building
you